[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir bienvenue
dans votre émission 7,8 débat impacts
climatiques variations boursières
concurrence internationale controverse
sanitaires et éthiques
et si le monde agricole ne traversait
pas qu'une crise mais changer de visage
fleuron de l'économie nationale
agroalimentaire française souffre et
décroche face et ses voisins espagnols
allemands et roumains faut-il produire
autrement si oui comment
quels sont vos être les conséquences
dans nos assiettes et notre portefeuille
pour débattre de ces questions
j'accueille haut sur ce qu'attend
quentin le guillou faut vous êtes si ray
lahood ans est secrétaire général
adjoint des jeunes agriculteurs de
l'ouest ile-de-france et j'accueille
également bénédicte rébéllion bonsoir
vous êtes responsable du développement
des territoires au sein du groupement
des agriculteurs bio français le gab
bonsoir à vous et merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté cette invitation alors avant de
commencer quelques chiffres notamment
sur la situation agricole dans les
yvelines
c'est deuxième département agricole
d'île de france 40% du territoire est
dédié à l'agriculture principalement aux
céréales et aux oléagineux seulement 4 %
de ces terres sont labellisés bio ou en
cours de course de conversion et c'est
le double des autres départements
franciliens mais c'est en dessous de la
moyenne nationale qui est de 5 5% alors
en disant il ya eu d'énormes
bouleversements dans le paysage agricole
notamment dans les yvelines au une
exploitation sur quatre a disparu mais
les survivants où elle par contre
continue de grossir plus du tiers
alors d'où cette question nous sommes
face une concentration concentration des
terres agricoles est ce que c'est un
accident est ce que c'est quelque chose
de voulu voulu non je pense pas en fait
c'est vraiment la conjoncture
aujourd'hui agricole en fonction
vraiment les prix la génère la nouvelle
génération aussi agricole qui se trouve
quand même de moins en moins il ya de
moins en moins de repreneur c'est un
métier quand même un petit peu dur assez
physique
donc on a beaucoup de jeunes qui qui qui
désertent un petit peu de monde agricole
beaucoup moins que dans les années 60 70
mais c'est encore le cas et la pression
financière et foncière
aujourd'hui fait que ma pour survivre on
est pour survivre on essaye de grossir
les exploitations cox est une nécessité
aujourd'hui un avis c'est un peu une
nécessité on commence à s'en rend compte
à tort je pense puisque on s'agrandit
ans a grandi mais on alourdit aussi nos
charges
donc je pense que va y avoir un
changement dans les amener dans les
années à venir casseurs à l'otan de
bascule à moyenne aujourd'hui ses 94
hectares pour une exploitation
aujourd'hui en ile-de-france 94 hectares
faut pas se voiler on vit plus avec 94
hectares
celui qui la perdre l'agriculteur qui en
conventionnel il ne vit plus 150
hectares il va pouvoir essayer de vivre
et essayez donc une année à coups durs
comme un peu les deux années qu'on a
connu c'est un petit peu compliqué face
à une nouvelle hécatombe en fait c'est
cette façon parce que les terres
agricoles y en a pas trente six mille
il y en a voilà donc un peu si la
grignotage urbain donc s'attaquer à
colas on va sur une plus grande
concentration pour vous ça va être en
gros ce qui ce qui va se passer
et du coup on se mord un petit peu le
bout c'est que on va on va arriver à des
parts d exploitation de 150 200 hectares
qui vont pas avoir deux repreneurs et il
va falloir cdc ferme-la du coup ça va
être déjà des exploitants déjà mis en
place
financièrement qu'ils vont pouvoir
essayer de reprendre ses exportations la
santé m ça va être très dur va falloir
vraiment un gros changement et ça je
pense que c'est un petit peu à l'état et
à l'europe de s'y pencher aujourd'hui
mais justement cette concentration
notamment des terres agricoles est ce
que c'est pas un facteur qui va jouer à
l'encontre de la progression notamment
du bio que vous essayez de développer
sur le territoire
non je pense ça va pas forcément à
l'encontre de ça on se rend compte que
en agriculture bio où on peut avoir des
des exploitations qui sont viables
justement sur des plus petites surfaces
donc effectivement en moyenne même en
grandes cultures on a des fermes qu'ils
sont viables à 150 hectares à peu près
parce qu'on a des prix de vente qui sont
plus élus en bio et parce qu'on a
parfois aussi des agriculteurs qui est
vendu une partie de leur production en
vente directe ou en transformant par
exemple une partie de leur blé en farine
et en tant au niveau de la ferme et ça
permet donc de garder une valeur ajoutée
sur la ferme et d'avoir du coup des
fermes viable sur des plus petites
surfaces et on a aussi pas mal de fermes
bio qui pratiquent le maraîchage
diversifié donc en circuit court par
exemple en amap et là on peut avoir des
structures de quelques hectares 3 4 ha
jusqu'à 10 hectares mais alors là c'est
un peu un autre métier effectivement fin
c'est un autre métier que le métier de
ces ralliés
et donc à ce qu'il faut cultiver
quasiment 70 espèces de légumes un peu
toute l'année est disponible un peu tout
le temps pour faire de la vente directe
qu'en tant que cela en est face
justement une sorte de pigeons qui sont
notamment métier d'agriculteur de façon
de produire l'alimentation est ce qu'on
n'est pas justement face à une
agriculture à deux vitesses c'est à dire
d'une part notamment la grande
consommation avec les produits de
dernier cri phytosanitaires et ses plus
de rentabilité c'est d'exporter de
l'autre côté un produit alimentaire plus
de niche ce qu on n'est pas face
aujourd'hui à ce constat là et comment
ça va se traduire dans l'avenir
notamment au niveau financier dans
l'avenir aujourd'hui sur les
exploitations moyennes
on est les trois quarts des agriculteurs
se remettent aujourd'hui en question
voilà c'est soit une transition au bio
ou soit on va intégrer une
diversification maraîchage du gîte à la
ferme voilà on cherche une
diversification
donc je ne sais pas si ça va vraiment à
deux vitesses parce que toute façon le
bio maintenant il a intégré je pense que
les pratiquement toutes les fermes de
france voilà en pensant à 4% mais mais
mais tout le monde l'a dans la tête tout
le monde a dans la tête
moi-même moi même ça ça fait un an que
je suis installé aujourd'hui je me dis
zut
est-ce que je vais pas louper le truc en
fait est-ce que j'aurais pas dû
m'installer en bio directement je l'ait
pas fait je regrette pas mais voilà on
se remet quand même tous en question
maintenant attention au bio faudrait que
ce n'est pas que tout le monde aille
d'un coup on entendait des choses est ce
que au niveau du prix aujourd'hui il
arrive à payer un prix il arriva à aider
une transition vers l'agriculture
biologique sera pas abaissé le prix on
entend
la russie maintenant qu'ils commençaient
à dire il aimerait bien que 20% de la
russie soit en agriculture biologique
donc je pense qu'ils vont casser les
prix voilà fait une réponse à
sanctionnant tout ça est ce que c'est le
bio devient mainstream à ce que des plus
rentables pour personne effectivement
c'est une inquiétude qu'on peut avoir en
même les acteurs déjà en bio sont
parfois ceux cette crainte ya ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que l'agriculture bio
elles se développent quand même assez
progressivement et voilà aujourd'hui la
dans la région n'a à peu près deux et
demi pour cent de la surface en bio avec
des même si c'est une progression nette
on n'est pas encore enfin le marché le
marché n'est pas submerger encore par
des produits bio aujourd'hui on
la production ne répond pas à la demande
et justement enfin les groupements
d'agriculteurs bio et notamment
certaines coopératives travail à la
structuration des filières pour absorber
en fait progressivement ses produits bio
qui viennent sur le marché pour
contractualiser avec des distributeurs
par exemple le réseau biocoop pour citer
lui en exemple sur des contres
accusations sur plusieurs années pour
garantir justement des prix stables pour
les agriculteurs donc effectivement on
est très vigilants par rapport à ça et
après on sait bien que les choses vont
évoluer en termes aussi de coûts
logistiques etc pour que effectivement
les produits bio après à l'achat seront
peut-être un peu plus bas pour les
consommateurs du fait qu'on va aussi
massifier la production et donc réduire
certains coûts logistiques de collecte
par exane est ce que ceci sera possible
notamment sans les subventions de l'état
ou des aides notamment et le département
ici et c'est notamment de promouvoir le
circuit court essayé d'acheter notamment
producteurs du territoire
est ce que vous trouvez que les
politiques s'investissent suffisamment
notamment pour structurer cette filière
là j'ai bien du bio codé et les
conventionnels qui sont déjà sur place
pour pour l'instant bas on a quelques
soucis il ya des régions de france où
aujourd'hui
il n'arrive plus vraiment à payer ils
ont en gros ils l'ont pas dit
ouvertement mais ils l'ont dit ils ont
dit attention stop
les arrêtés de 2,2 comment dire de de
changer au d'exploitation pour devenir
bio calmez-vous un petit peu on est où
on est limite limite niveau niveau
finance on va pas pouvoir vous suivre
donc
ça a calmé un petit peu alors que de
l'autre côté on a les médias le
consommateur qui nous pousse à aller
vers le bio quand même donc s'armer
quand même ça fait beaucoup de questions
on ne sait pas vraiment où est ce qu'on
va
après il ya les aides de l'état ya la
pac et autres ça c'est des trucs moi
personnellement si je pouvais m'en
passer je veux le frais largement
aujourd'hui je vis grâce à la pac est ce
que ce que j'ai vendu ce que j'ai vendu
samassa m'est revenue à zéro voire même
moins et quelques c'est la pac qui me
permet aujourd'hui me dégager un salaire
donc en gros qu'est-ce qu'on ait
aujourd'hui ce qu'on était agriculteur
de de l'état je sais pas je donc est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir vraiment bien suivre
toutes les transitions vers le bio est
ensuite bien accompagner le bio jusqu'au
bout aujourd'hui est un gros point
d'interrogation
enfin c'est vrai qu'il ya effectivement
une attente de la part des pouvoirs
publics et il ya un certain flou et
effectivement il ya besoin d' aide
importante au moment du changement de du
changement des fermes vers la bio on n'a
pas de conversion nous
ne
se mobilisent aussi pour ce qu'on
appelle les aides au maintien qu'on
préfère appeler les aide la
reconnaissance lors ça c'était déjà
d'état qui a aidé les fermes pendant
trois ans notamment pour un stabilisé et
le gouvernement a annoncé qu'ils
allaient tout simplement supprimées
arrêter de financer ça en 2018 pourquoi
pour vous c'est que je dois
préjudiciable pour la filière c'est de
toute façon il ya tellement de demeures
dont parce qu'il ya toujours besoin
justement de faim de sécuriser cette
phase de conversion
puisque c'est des changements très
importants de pratique c'est des risques
aussi très important donc même si au
final les prix payés aux producteurs
sont plus importants il ya vraiment ce
soutien qui est qui et qui est
primordial pour les agriculteurs et même
après au delà de la période de
conversion on considère que alors les
est normalement son plus faible dont on
considère que c'est important aussi de
rémunérer rémunérer ses services
environnementaux que rendre les
agriculteurs par rapport à la protection
de l'eau par exemple la protection de la
biodiversité ajustements d'ici une
semaine va co débuté le salon de
l'agriculture ce sera le premier
notamment d' emmanuel macron qui a
promis il ya quelques mois il ya tout
juste un mois un nouveau printemps pour
le monde de l'agriculture
pour cela il a notamment prévu de
dévoiler son plan d'investissement de 5
milliards peut-être cette semaine
peut-être ces prochaines semaines
est ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
redoutez notamment ce que vous pensez
que le gouvernement l'a bien compris les
enjeux les intérêts des agriculteurs
jusqu'à là
pour ma part julliard non au terme
agricoles je pense que emmanuel macron
l'ordre pendant les élections a dit des
choses a promis on va pas dire promettre
mais pratiquement il a ici promettre des
choses aujourd'hui c'est pas tenu du
tout on voit ni une côté agricole donc
là on attend on prend vraiment du recul
sur sur ces annonces
on attend vraiment pour l'instant on
sait pas voilà on trouve un on le voit
on a une barrière un petit peu avec lui
même fin pour l'instant jean dufaux that
he sur autres un bon voilà puis après
c'est plein d'autres choses de la vie du
quotidien même que ce soient agricoles
ou agricole voient le monde rural quand
même et un petit peu mis un petit peu de
côté on attend on attend toutes ces
belles promesses belles paroles j'espère
qu'elles seront mises à profit et
jusqu'au bout d'accord pour l'instant
pourrait dans ce temps perdu ce soir
ce nouveau printemps les premiers et
vous est ce que vous attendez des
mesures concrètes notamment pour bio il
semblait vouloir annoncer quelque chose
alors je suis pas forcément très très
haut
au fait la des dernières actualités ce
que je sais c'est qu'au niveau de la
fnab donc la fédération nationale
d'agriculture biologique
donc on est en lien avec les différents
acteurs au niveau de la politique
agricole au niveau français et donc on
est très en attente effectivement de
voir quel soutien sera apporté à la
filière bio pour l'instant on a été
assez déçu effectivement des annonces
faites et par rapport effectivement aux
promesses qui avaient pu être évoquées
auparavant
donc je pense qu'on a un petit peu même
état d'esprit on va voir les annonces et
les choses concrètes qui pourront sortir
à l'occasion du salon de l'agriculture
très bien mais côté c'est la fin de ce
débat merci à vous d'avoir participé
quant à vous je vous invite à voir
revoir sur notre site internet cette
émission je vous souhaite une agréable
soirée à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]